[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv 78
pour un nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés
votre rendez vous hebdomadaire pour
débattre discuter et réfléchir sur les
grands enjeux qui font l'actualité
versailles chevreuse rambouillet plaisir
depuis plusieurs semaines des
mobilisations de soignants se
multiplient leurs griefs s'ils se
sentent exclus oubliée du secteur de la
santé
la concertation pour améliorer les
conditions de travail la prise en charge
des malades
une consultation qui a notamment abouti
à une hausse des rémunérations mais
certains professionnels du milieu ne
devrait pas en bénéficier il s'estime
donc oublié du ségur rires non pas avec
nos invités didier baichère député la
république en marche de la première
circonscription des yvelines et membre
de la commission des affaires sociales
bonsoir maison et caroline andré
orthophoniste au kansas centre d'action
médico-sociale de trappes
bonsoir bonsoir et christophe salomon
membres du chsct le comité d'hygiène de
sécurité des conditions de travail et
représentant cfdt de l'hôpital
gérontologique de chevreuse bonsoir bon
bah alors le ségur la santé c'est 50
jours de travaux 90 parties prenantes et
organisations syndicales 118 1400 ses
participants à la consultation en ligne
je me tourne je me tourne d'abord vers
nos invités professionnels de la santé
caroline landry christophe salomon est
ce que vous avez vous même participé à
cette consultation en ligne
non monsieur salomon peut-être en
premier en fait elles par le biais de
famille k départementale oui et vous
même madame andrée vous avez pu
participer en tant que professionnel de
santé non je n'ai passé j'ai peut-être
revoir sur le mail mais j'aime que j'ai
pas pris le temps de répondre aux
questions alors lancé en mai les travaux
se sont achevés le 10 juillet dernier
les accords du ségur de la santé ont été
signés par jean castex premier ministre
et olivier
rend le ministre des solidarités et de
la santé alors quelques chiffres qui ont
qui sont sortis de cette signature le
ségur ses 19 milliards d'euros
d'investissements dans le système de
santé pour améliorer la prise en charge
des patients et le quotidien des
soignants 8,2 milliards d'euros pour
veut revaloriser les métiers des
établissements de santé des ehpad
reconnaître l'engagement des soignants
au service de la santé des français
quinze mille recrutement à l'hôpital
public ou encore financer l'ouverture ou
la réouverture de 4 me lie à la demande
se sont que quelques exemples alors je
le disais certains professionnels se
sont oubliés parce c'est dur de
nombreuses manifestations se déroulent
un peu partout en france car en ligne
andré pourquoi le centre d'action
médico-sociale de trappes s'est
mobilisée et c'est une mobilisation
organisée avec le centre de soins
d'accompagnement et de prévention des
addictions de versailles et le
dispositif d'intervention d'intervention
précoce en autisme alors nous sommes un
service du centre hospitalier de mignon
mais nous sommes un service médico
social cela veut dire que l'hôpital nous
gèrent avec un budget annexe
donc ça ce sont des questions juridiques
mais nous sommes des agents de l'hôpital
de millau et nous ne bénéficions pas de
la revalorisation du complément à diar
de traitement qui est annoncée de 183
euros nets mensuels
voilà tout simplement non ça me réveille
chez votre implication la vôtre et celle
de vos confrères dans ses différents
services depuis le début de la crise
est-ce que vous avez été confronté
directement à la commune alors
directement pas comme les soignants qui
travaillent en service infirmier en
urgence par contre nous n'avons pas
fermé nos services nous avons continué à
recevoir des patients moins que
d'habitude dans des conditions
différentes puisque nous n'avions pas le
droit d'être tous ensemble en même temps
mais nous avons assuré des permanences
voilà on a été au téléphone auprès des
gens à domicile quand c'était nécessaire
on n'a jamais arrêté on a fonctionné on
a continué à fonctionner comme on a pu
voilà auprès de nos patients les
psychologues de nos services ont été
mobilisés sur l'hôpital mignon c'est à
dire qu'elles sont fait partie du pool
des psychologues qui était le soutien
auprès des auprès des agents dans tous
les services
voilà et de toute manière nous recevons
les appels à mobilisation de la
direction à chaque fois nous sommes au
courant du plan blanc voilà s'il faut se
mobiliser nous avons décollé qui ont été
travaillés sur l'ehpad de mignon on a
aussi travaillé en pédiatrie
alors c'est des épiphénomènes une et
voilà nous sommes des personnels
hospitaliers et que des personnels
hospitaliers
même question pour vous christophe
salomon alors vous n'avez pas le même
public de patients mais ce que vous avez
rencontré les mêmes problématiques
est-ce que vous avez été confronté
directement au virus
alors oui dans l'établissement il ya eu
le virus qui d'ailleurs se préoccupe pas
de savoir s'il est dans une partie
médico-social une partie sanitaire
on a eu plusieurs cas et on a eu un
cluster donc là pour pour vous donner un
petit peu unités de l'établissement a en
interne on n'attire pas grand service on
a affaire à des parades
on a intérêt à vite usd donc les deux
services qui sont confirmées par par la
revalorisation et on a un service maison
d'accueil spécialisée qui lui de l'état
et en externe
on a le soin domicile vous ça donne une
situation où on a deux services qui font
exclus du ségur et deux services qui
sont
qui sont confirmés donc vous pouvez
imaginer sur le même lieu
sur les 170 agents de l'établissement il
ya presque pile 50% kilkee qui en
bénéficient et le rêve des 50 cent qui
n'en bénéficient pas pareil j'ai aussi
quand même alerté sur la situation
particulière des services généraux je
vais pas avoir le temps là tous de les
récupérer mais les pharmacies
rééducation à tous les services qui font
transfert comme puisque généraux et qui
se retrouve dans une situation où selon
les affectations budgétaires
bah on se retrouve avec des personnes
qui bénéficient à hauteur de 30%
notre qui bénéficia odeur de 0% et
d'autres qui bénéficie à hauteur de 100%
donc moi je je je comprends pas comment
on a pu arriver à cette situation là
dont j'ai suivi un petit peu les
négociations je fais que la cfdt a
alerté sur cette question là
malheureusement vu où on se trouve
maintenant visiblement on n'a pas été
entendu à ce moment là je pense aussi
qu'il ya des questions de calendrier qui
font qu'ils sont percutés notamment le
calendrier qui a été avancé mais mais
c'est juste impossible par vous imaginez
en tant que directeur vous avez trois
personnes dans le même service et vous
pouvez défilé qui bénéficient qu'ils
bénéficient pas un pays et un peuple on
comprend bien donc selon les sites
toujours n'est pas concerné didier
baichère justement comment ont été
identifiés les personnes qui
bénéficierait alors là on parle de cette
prime de fin n'ont pas cette prime
justement cette revalorisation salariale
de 183 euros nets
c'est pas une prime des divers comment
on a identifié au niveau du gouvernement
de l'assemblée nationale aussi quels
professionnels de santé y aurait le
droit et pas le droit
alors déjà pour remettre les choses dans
leur contexte très clairement il s'agit
d'une négociation qui a eu lieu avec les
partenaires sociaux
ce n'est pas un choix uniquement des
parlementaires ou
du gouvernement moi j'ai eu la chance
d'en 2018
le vice-président de la commission d'
enquête sur l'égal accès aux soins et
qui a pointé un certain nombre de
déficit au niveau des hôpitaux et
globalement des professions de santé et
donc quand on a fait un certain nombre
de recommandations
je pense en particulier à l'état
absolument déplorable des structures
médico-sociales de du quasi points
d'arrêts point mort des relations entre
la ville et l'hôpital
la nécessité de numériser les structures
de manière importante
tous ces points là en fait tousser
constat avait été fait et donc il ya par
exemple 6 milliards d'euros
d'investissements qui ont été mis la
négociation et donc les négociateurs ont
décidé de se mettre d'accord sur la
priorité à donner aux établissements de
santé et aux ehpad
donc ça c'est est le résultat de la
négociation du ségur qui a donné ce
résultat est ce que vous en tant que
député de la première circonscription
alesi pardon je vous ai coupé et il se
trouve que comme on est tout à fait
conscient de l'injustice dont on est en
train de parler et que je perçois tout à
fait et qui est parfaitement légitime
on s'est battus à la commission des
affaires sociales au moment de l'examen
du budget 2010 21 courts au moins dans
un premier temps sur la partie des
personnes qui était centré sur le soin
domicile donc on reste dans le domaine
stricte delà de la santé qui était
l'objectif du ségur en tout cas
l'objectif que les partenaires sociaux
et les négociateurs s'étaient fixé et on
a rajouté 200 millions d'euros dans le
budget 2021 pour pouvoir traiter une
partie des oubliés on va les appeler
comme ça en rajoutant 200 millions
d'euros dans le budget de ville 21 pour
pouvoir les traiter faire dérober deux
réalisations de métier maintenant il
reste effectivement le secteur du
médico-social qui suivant son statut
madame andrée l'a très bien dit vous
avez de multiples financeurs
nouvellement la région pour avoir la
carte pour l'hôpital public enfin il ya
vraiment souvent les structures le
multiple financeurs qui nécessite de
faire une analyse beaucoup plus
approfondie pour faire ses revenus
risation de métier et de salaires
donc c'est pour ça que jean castex a
demandé
ou à l'ancien préfet un préfet l'ancien
patron de la rs de l'aquitaine à michel
laforcade de travailler en ce début
d'année 2021 pour avoir des propositions
de revalorisation sur la partie médico
social qui avait été exclu que j'insiste
volontairement par les négociateurs dans
le secteur de la santé ça signifie donc
le ségur qui a été volé quelques temps
va bouger
je vais vous donner mais la parole
monsieur salomon monsieur v cher ça peut
bouger en fait tout n'est pas encore
établie ben ça sera pas en lien avec le
ségur mais vous imaginez bien que la
discussion que nous avons ce soir nous
l'avons tous eu dans notre
circonscription
on a tous été amenés à recevoir les
personnes qui estimait ou kiss qui se
trouve être en lien avec les hôpitaux et
est-ce que vous avez décrit sur celle
roman madame andrée quand on est dans
une structure vous avez 80% des
personnes qui vont toucher une
revalorisation de salaires et une
revalorisation de carrière et qu'une
seule partie ne va pas les toucher on
comprend bien même ne serait-ce qu on ne
les quittez par rapport à son employeur
ça pose question
donc il est évidemment question de
rester dans cette situation maintenant
encore une fois de bonne foi par rapport
aux négociateurs parce que c'est pas une
décision unique du du gouvernement ou
des coûts des débutants pour le secteur
de la santé l'urgence le besoin absolu
c'était de traiter strictement les
secteurs santé et les ehpad publics
c'est ça qui est sur quoi les partis
nationaux s'étaient mis d'accord les qui
explique qu'ils aient un certain nombre
de personnes qui se trouvent exclus
aujourd'hui la revalorisation des
salaires
monsieur salomon vous souhaitez réagir
oui par rapport aux partenaires sociaux
la fdt l'affecté d'alerté sur cette
question là et elle a toujours été sur
la position de mener de front toutes les
négociations en même temps donc pour
retrouver justement dans cette situation
là parce que vous vous imaginez quand
même à la place d'un directeur qui se
retrouve dans cette situation là est
juste impossible à gérer ces faits comme
ça je comprends même pas comment on
puisse imaginer que ce soit viable et
quand il était impossible et pour la
question de l'affronter parce qu'on en
fait là on voit ça d'une manière
extrêmement administrative mais dans en
réalité dans les établissements la
maison d'accueil spécialisée ou dans mon
établissement est bien plus médicalisée
que la partie des grades
si on va par là évidemment sur le papier
les deux médico-social d'ailleurs c'est
aussi pourquoi choisir d pad et pas le
reste de musique au social mais en
vérité quitter sa le cul refaire ce qui
ferait le plus médicalisée il ya des
maisons d'accueil spécialisées qui font
extrêmement médical y met en avant une
fin de toute manière mais sincèrement
pardon pardon de vous couper je pense
que dia absolument pas dans notre esprit
je peux vous assurer que les députés qui
sont dans la commission des affaires
sociales qui traitent ces sujets toutes
les semaines on a pas dans notre idée de
faire une hiérarchie entre ceux qui ont
une robe ce que je n'ai pas droit
on est quand on met 19 milliards l'été
revient mais la santé et les épaves
non jamais jamais bénéficié depuis 30
ans de la revue de l'année nécessaire et
indispensable maintenant vous avez
raison il fait laquelle les ligues mis à
perdre et lui ce point d'atterrissage
pour les autres personnels
on l'entend il ya aussi une sensation de
madame andrée vous aussi en tant que
professionnel est ce que je vois lever
la main mais est ce que ça vaut aussi le
sentiment d'une dévalorisation d'être
humain un peu à part monsieur le chien
dit que il travaille il rencontre est-ce
que vous aussi vous avez pu rencontrer
le député de votre secteur
eh bien nous lui avons écrit un mail à
notre frère on attend encore sa réponse
le 20 novembre notre nous avons écrit
ainsi qu'à monsieur benassaya les
différents maire du chesnay de trappes
de versailles on attend des réponses on
a été reçus à la grèce nous avons été
reçus en préfecture alors par des gens
fort aimable qui n'avait pas beaucoup de
réponses et des explications à nous
donner
voilà par les explications que nous
annonce aux explications techniques
juridiques franchement elles ne
conviennent pas c'est bien pour ça qu'on
continue à se manifester
voilà il faudrait pas oublier
effectivement les masses les femmes
l'hexa par les canucks on s'occupe de
personnes handicapées de personnes
seules deux personnes qui n'ont pas la
voie et ils n'ont pas parole c'est pas
eux qui vont aller demain en fauteuil
blanc hancock dans les rues pour aller
taper au ministère ils prennent ce qu'on
leur donne et alors par exemple de ce
que je connais estime domaines d'action
médico sociale précoce isker à éviter
les sûr en tout cas à faire en sorte que
les enfants soient pris en charge très
facilement en cas de troubles du
développement de diack de diagnostic
avéré de handicap
on est pris en fait entre les
recommandations de pratique de la haute
autorité de santé qui nous demande
d'accueillir et de traiter les enfants
le plus précocement possible demain je
veux dire financièrement aussi pour
éviter des sur handicap et des choses
lourdes et on essaye de le faire avec
les moyens du bord surtout quand on est
un cadre hospitalier qui vit comme
l'hôpital et donc du coup il ya un
moment donné où c'est tentant dable
voiliers ont par exemple on a un membre
de notre équipe qui travaillait à
l'hôpital
au mois d'octobre elle a touché la
moitié puisque c'est par moi dire pour
l'instant ni complètement du complément
indiciaire de très près elle est arrivée
en novembre sur 1 sur le même poste et
en novembre elle dit moi à son premier
jour de travail qu elle ne l'aura plus
sur complément a dit hier de 13 mois
c'est drôle elle a pas tellement envie
de rigoler justement voilà dans quelques
temps
tout le monde partira alors justement on
parle beaucoup la de cette
revalorisation salariale qui pourraient
ça aussi suire certaines envies
professionnelles dans ce secteur il ya
aussi un investissement perdre pour les
projets médicaux sociaux prioritaires il
y aura 2,1 milliards d'euros sur cinq
ans dont 0,6 milliard pour le numérique
pour la transformation la rénovation et
l'équipement dans les établissements
didier baichère ce ségur il est aussi
pour les conditions de travail ce n'est
pas qu'une question financière est bien
bien sûr mais encore une fois et on en
bénéficie dans les yvelines j'ai eu
l'occasion il ya quelques semaines sur
cette même antenne d'expliquer que nous
avons obtenus parce qu'on a fait un
travail conjoint avec les équipes de
santé des territoires l'hôpital mindo et
la pta 78 nous avons obtenu
l'expérimentation du saas dans les
yvelines et donc ça ça fait partie du
financement des deux milliards dont vous
parlez bien sûr mais s'il si on revient
à notre sujet encore une fois je pense
que le débat
enfin je comprends votre désarroi ray
c'est pour ça qu'il ya cette émission
qu'on a obtenu cette mission mode
analyse pour faire les compléments mais
je voudrais aussi que les personnes qui
nous écoutent comprennent bien que dans
la masse des priorités moi c'est pas moi
qui pendant dix ans est abandonné
l'hôpital voilà moi je suis arrivé j'ai
mené une commission denquête quand
j'étais vice-président et on a fait le
constat peut dire on va à la catastrophe
et ce constat est les propositions qui
ont été faites où je donnais ma santé
2022 et le ségur et les 19 milliards
on nous parle en ce 9 il ya donc oui
tout le monde n'est pas servi
aujourd'hui oui encore et d'ailleurs
michel laforcade devra travailler sur
les revalorisations des métiers des
personnes qui ont du médico-social qui
sont pas encore abordé et ça parce que
vous le savez aussi bien que moi quand
on est durs multi financement multi
structure et qu'on parle de la carrière
et du contrat de travail
ça devient extrêmement compliqué donc
cette chose là elles doivent être
simplifiées pas nous n'avions pas
effectivement des parcours qui
souhaitent valoriser à l'hôpital et
mieux rémunéré et moins bien rémunérés
dans le médico social en ya pas de rire
archi la nécessité d'avoir tous les
métiers qui s'occupe de l'accompagnement
des personnes les plus en difficulté
font partie de nos priorités
ça n'a pas été encore une fois je ge ge
j'aime l'idée qu'il ya eu une
négociation avec les partenaires sociaux
donc ne renvoyons pas encore une fois la
responsabilité de
avantage dès 19h à l'unique arbitrages
du gouvernement d écouter parce qu'on a
tout simplement ses collègues salon -
les i je vous en prie non mais moi j'ai
quand même du mal à entendre cet
argument qui revient tout le temps de
les partenaires sociaux étaient là puis
effectivement il était là la cab était
est signataire
elle est fière de l'avoir été battu qu'à
une véritable avancée mais il n'empêche
qu'on a alerté dès le départ sur le fait
qu'il pouvait pas y avoir de
hiérarchisation
parce que si vous faites ça ça veut dire
que vous fabriquez une partie j'aime les
ulves vous donner l'exemple du soin à
domicile
on essaie d'avoir une politique qui
permet de garder les gens à domicile le
plus longtemps possible
là on est dans une situation où les
thèmes de soins à domicile one suis donc
cette idée de choisir une partie
elle sait qui va passer concrètement et
services de trois domiciles que jamais
déterminés
il ya beaucoup de professionnels donc ce
qui va vouloir aller travailler dans les
facs de droit de 8,6 en étant payés
nettement moins sûr à domicile je le dis
dans mon introduction dans le budget
2021 que nous avons voté commission des
affaires sociales a fait rajouter a fait
rajouter au 19 mai met 200 millions
d'euros pour traiter exclusivement le
domicile donc ce que vous dites evry et
et l'invisible pompiers belges n'ont
rien compris au budget de la france
c'est tous les ans les priorités donc
monde a décidé jeudi ne vous coupez pas
les paroles essaie de vous laisser de
vous laisser parler
madame andrée va vouloir réagir aussi
monsieur s'allongeant leçon que ce que
monsieur béchard vous dit sur l'avancée
de la commission notamment des affaires
sociales ça ne vous rassure pas non ça
me rassure pas parce qu'on fait de bien
comprendre qu'il faut tout mener de
front et déjà impose déjà question mais
voilà mais c'est de toute manière
la plus haute sur lequel la fia l'a dit
dès le départ et sur lequel on n'a
jamais réussi à vous d'y réagir avant
que je redonne la parole à monsieur
pêcheurs oui merci
alors effectuons depuis plusieurs
semaines chaque fois qu on rencontre
quelqu'un on vous demande d'attendre
il va se passer quelque chose ok très
bien alors premièrement va attendre
combien de temps ça va
voilà ok très bien ensuite bon à la fin
du médico-social réfléchir à tout ça
mais quid du médico-social hospitalier
est-ce qu'on moment médico social va
être consternés ben finalement là on
sera des hospitaliers et on nous dira ah
bah non
voilà c'est passé quelque chose avant un
mois on est un petit peu parano mais bon
voilà en tout cas on n'est pas très
rassurée vous êtes donc on se demande
bien à quelle sauce on va être mangé moi
je veux bien entendre qu'on ne fasse pas
le même métier et voilà pourquoi il
infirme iran médico social elle fera pas
une chose que à l'hôpital bon peu
importe
et puis voilà on bientôt on va attendre
et très concrètement on grogne pas pour
rien moi je les fais le calcul pour ma
petite personne
183 euros net par mois rapporté à mon
temps de travail alentours horaire est
ce que vous imaginez combien de temps de
travail ça courait sa course être à quoi
ça correct
est ce que vous savez mais vous avez
entièrement raison
une fois l'émission est d ailleurs pour
être précis madame andrée la mission qui
a été confiée à michel de la focale elle
est bien sûr le betico social
hospitalier donc il s'agit bien pour lui
de revenir avec des propositions au
premier trimestre 2010 21 sur la
réorganisation de ses activités
donc on est enfin à chaque fois c'est
difficile jeune ou vaguement démocratie
on parle mais vous pouvez suivre si vous
voulez les commissions des affaires
sociales s'est on est mobilisé
jacky gouvernement pour que y ait des
solutions concrètes qu'ils soient
apportées en 2021 sur le sujet ça c'est
certain
sous les pavés en référé
mais déjà on fait pas on fait pas la
négociation à la télé moi je suis pas
négocié capteurs et vous non plus donc
on laissera les partenaires sociaux ont
mandaté comme la cfdt qui a
effectivement trouvé que 19 milliards
c'était fantastique et qu'il fallait
signer mais qui a alerté sur le fait
qu'on pouvait pas faire de
discrimination entre les personnes donc
cette négociation elle va continuer
évidemment avec les syndicats le rythme
puisqu'il mais on a on a vraiment faim
comprenez je pense que ce travail d
analyse sur ces multi structure multi
statut n'a jamais été fait et nous
conduire en fait pour la situation est
dans la discussion nous avons donc il
faut faire du ménage de la simplicité et
voir quelles sont les carrières que nous
voulons proposer et comment on va le
financer avec les différents acteurs
vous savez moi j'ai des collègues
j'étais extrêmement surpris quand on a
dit le versement des primes
exceptionnelles au moment de l'épisode
locaux vides comme les primes doivent
être versés dans les départements et
vous savez du département chacun est
comme il adore les gens ils avaient
entendu à la télé qu'il y avait une
prime qui était versée il pensait que
dans la même chose là vous avez des
parts des départements qui ont décidé de
pas tous versé parce qu'effectivement
c'est le social est de la responsabilité
des départements
donc si certains ce n'est pas le cas
dans les yvelines main mais moi j'ai des
collègues qui ont qui ont dû expliquer
qu' il y avait une recommandation et un
budget qui avait été trouvé et le
département n'avait pas consommé cette
manière donc ce success ces différents
statuts avec ses différents financeurs
qui cohabitent rend complexe la
visibilité là où peut-être sur la santé
sur les ébats public c'était beaucoup
plus simple de travailler sur la grille
de la minoration sur l'augmentation que
l'ensemble des personnels ac c'est quand
même deux millions de personnes qui vont
être revalorisées c'est pas c'est pas
rien c'est beaucoup beaucoup de monde
donc c'est pas possible ça n'est pas
possible de regarder cette situation
monsieur salomon je suis entièrement
d'accord avec vous et pouvait compter
sur inception et il faut une réponse
rapide
alors allez-y monsieur réal ont très
très vite parce qu'il nous reste une
petite trentaine de secondes
je vous en prie
j'ai dit qu'une réponse rapide dont ont
pu attendre la les services il obtenir
très rapidement par perdre leur
personnel donc là on n'a pas et pas le
premier semestre de 2021 tout on est
maintenant à choisir je vais vous
laisser terminer vous même madame andrée
vous vous dire ajouter quelque chose on
a vraiment que quelques secondes
oui louis basse et pour illustrer voilà
l'hôpital de plaisir 350 personnes sont
concernées une cinquantaine au minimum
il ya déjà quinze jours ont demandé leur
demande de mutation
c'est tout ça et illustrations elle est
la voix l'a dit hier je vais vous donner
le mot de la fin parce que monsieur
salomon madame andrée se sont exprimés
encore une fois je pense que ce combat
que vous menez il est absolument
légitime et les députés de la commission
des affaires sociales en particulier
sont parfaitement sensibilisés au sujet
est pas fort parfaitement supporter ifs
maintenant il ya cette mission d'
analyse qui va avoir lieu au premier
trimestre on va attendre les conclusions
pour voir les propositions qui vont être
faites par cet ancien dirigeant de l'as
des rays qui connaît bien les sujets et
en fonction de ta la négociation mais ce
serait ouvrir
moi je n'ai aucun doute sur le fait qu
on atterrira sur quelque chose important
et qui conviendra à tout le monde on va
s'arrêter sur ces mots là j'imagine
caroline andré sacré simplement que vous
allez continuer à vous un mobiliser
nature dès vendredi des membres renier
on va enlever le permet les habitants ne
brûle très bien merci en tout cas à tous
les trois d'avoir accepté cette notre
invitation
c'était sûr que ce sujet à vous ferez
réagir
de notre côté c'est la fin de ce sept
huit sociétés on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
[Musique]